temps commençait par un sujet très
français en effet puisqu'il s'agit des
de la mortalité routière
regardez ce petit panneau qui vous
montre les nombres de tués au premier
semestre 2018 et au premier semestre
2010 9 ça se passe en france
métropolitaine et les chiffres sont à
peu près équivalents il ya neuf morts de
moins au premier semestre 2010 9515
personnes ont été tuées sur les routes
est ce qu'on peut dire du coup que les
80 kilomètres heure qui était donc en
vigueur au premier semestre de cette
année puisque je vous rappelle que ça a
commencé au milieu de l'année dernière
est ce qu'on peut dire que cette mesure
n'a pas été très efficace c'est pas le
point de vue de christophe castaner lui
compte différemment il considère que les
80 kilomètres heure ont permis
d'épargner 206 vies écoutez
l'abaissement des vitesses à 80
kilomètres a permis d'épargner au
minimum 200 civils
évidemment beaucoup beaucoup plus de
blessés
206 vies c'est un chiffre qui sans nul
doute aurait été aurait été plus
important encore sans les dégradations
et les descriptions de radars alors en
fait le ministre accuse façon différente
puisqu'il prend la moyenne des morts des
années précédentes et il se base sur une
année de 2 glissante comme on dit chez
les statisticiens de 80 km donc ces
chiffres sont pas complètement
concordants voici avant de vous demander
votre point de vue le témoignage d'un
président de conseil départemental c'est
patrick septiers qui est le président du
conseil de seine et marne
il était ce matin sur rmc et pour lui
les 80 km heure ne sont pas concluants
et donc il va repasser sur son
département à 90 nous n'avons pas
constaté de baisse significative de la
mortalité sur les routes la vitesse
augmente et les derniers accidents que
nous avons eu ce sont des accidents qui
ne sont pas liées à la vitesse ce sont
des personnes qui utilisaient
téléphone donc nous allons remettre
à peu près 500 kilomètres sur les
quelque 1300 que nous avons d'euros
département qu'avec 90 km/h dans les
mois à venir
voilà je précise mon propos il va pas
remettre toutes les routes donc à 90 et
simplement 10% d'entre elles 10% des
routes départementales
car certes il peut y avoir débat sur les
chiffres mais on peut dire que l'impact
des 80 km/heure et pas forcément
spectaculaires en matière de deux morts
en moins alors moi je trouve que c'est
beaucoup trop tôt pour le dire n'importe
quel expérimentation ne prévoit au moins
deux ans quel que soit le domaine
d'ailleurs pour tirer des conclusions
donc c'est un peu rapide et bon ça fait
partie du petit jeu aussi aux politiques
habituels surtout que c'est une mesure
qui a suscité beaucoup beaucoup de
polémiques donc bon c'est de bonne
guerre je dirais mais je crois qu'on
peut absolument pas en tirer un bilan
par ailleurs il faut quand même se
réjouir quel que soit le chiffre c'est
quand même ce sont quand même des vies
on peut pas dire dans un accident ou
dans un incendie par exemple à 15
personnes qui sont morts quel horreur et
puis de ne pas tenir compte de la baisse
de la mortalité sur les routes
lorsqu'il s'agit précisément de
limitation de vitesse ça me paraît un
peu bizarre
par ailleurs il se trouve que c'est
quand même tout à fait établi que une
baisse une réduction de la vitesse sur
les routes de 10% pour être très précis
s'est réduit la mortalité sur les routes
de 40% donc c'est complètement absurde
de contester les faits que ça le côté
efficace d'une mesure de cet ordre là et
dernier point aucun aucun département
n'a prévu de revenir à la situation
antérieure ou qu'un certain disent
effectivement on va pas on va on va pas
comment dire on va sur certains tronçons
rétablir les 90 enfin c'est très très
partagés oui comment certains restent
sur les 80 donc c'est bien dire quand
même que sa porte est quelque part dans
le pays
ra notre point de vue je suis assez
d'accord avec ce que vous venez de dire
je pense que sur les 80 km heure a été
ce qui a été reproché au gouvernement
c'est patent passé 85 80 que la méthode
indien on va le faire de manière hyper
centralisé et uniforme sur l'ensemble du
territoire
est ce que disent les départements
aujourd'hui c'est que sur certains
tronçons effectivement ça a du sens de
rester à 90
de passer à 80 et ça a été très mal pris
parce qu'il y avait été perçu comme une
mesure très parisienne de gens qui ne
prennent pas la voiture tous les jours
mais je pense que l'ensemble des
français comprennent le mec sur certains
tronçons dangereux plus ou moins
dangereux ça a du sens de passer à 80
plutôt que de rester à 90 comme dans
d'autres on pourrait peut-être aussi les
traces en tout 90 voici l'avis de nos
internautes
ils sont plutôt pour un retour aux 90
km/heure à 71% et voici deux
commentaires d'avoir celui de cij qui
nous dit c'est totalement stupide de
vouloir comparer une année sur l'autre
plus et en l'occurrence six mois par
rapport à six autres mois dans le dans
les chiffres que je vous soumettez tout
à l'heure impossible de recréer
exactement les mêmes conditions par
exemple la météo en revanche si tu dis
il est contre le fait que les 80 km
heure soit imposé depuis paris sans
aucune réflexion locale
il rejoint votre propos est roi nanan et
puis ce point de vue de nicole qui est
contre les 80 kilomètres heure
comment peut-on asséné le fait que cette
situation ait pu faire baisser la
mortalité sans statistiques réelles
geneviève goetzinger c'est un bon sujet
de communication parce que parce que
dans cette histoire
chacun voit la vérité un peu comme il
veut à partir de ses propres chiffres
ça a été assez mal à la communication
était assez mal fait c'est quand même un
sujet qui a pourri la ville président de
la république et du premier ministre qui
a suscité des dissensions aussi à un
moment au sein de l'exécutif
après sur le fond il a quand même été
calculée dans ce rapport que pour
l'automobiliste moyen ça lui faisait une
seconde de plus par kilomètre sur son
trajet donc très honnêtement la réalité
du changement et de l'impact sur sa vie
quotidienne et quand même égal à zéro
quasiment à zéro égale à une seconde par
kilomètre donc peu de choses ce qui a
été contestée et ce qui a été mal
expliquée aussi ce qui a pu sembler mal
expliqué mal compris c'est que on ne
prennent en compte en terme de mortalité
on donne cet argument de mortalité sans
tenir compte du reste c'est à dire des
incivilités au volant c'est à dire de la
capacité quelquefois bien conduire c'est
à dire de la vétusté des automobiles
c'est à dire de l'état de la chaussée
c'est à dire de tout certain nombre
d'autres phénomènes qui sont pas du tout
qui ont pas du tout était pris en compte
et qui aurait dû aussi être intégré à la
réflexion générale sur l'automobile
olivier la question est ce que c'est ce
bilan rationnelle ou est-ce que c'est
pas là la perception qu'ont les français
de savoir est ce que c'est une mesure de
salubrité publique ou une mesure de
restriction de leur liberté
je crois qu'on est dans un débat qui est
faussement rationnelle l'argument qui
est avancé qui semble absolument
indiscutable de 1500 mah saah baisser
c'est bien et c'est encore trop si on
rentre dans cette logique il faudrait se
dire que 700 morts ce serait mieux mais
ce serait encore trop donc pourquoi ne
pas aller à 720 et dans ce cas là il ya
une solution c'est par exemple de rouler
à 50 à l'heure il ya un moment donné il
faut accepter un effet de seuil et je
pense que de calculer uniquement la
mortalité en fonction de la vitesse
ça n'est pas prendre en compte tous les
facteurs qui créent et qui provoque un
accident et c'est se focaliser
uniquement sur la vitesse
vous avez raison sur le fait que ça ne
change pas grand chose sur le sur le
temps de trajet mais c'est perçu comme
une contrainte supplémentaire et surtout
comme une contrainte vous vous l'avez
dit qui est presque jacobine qui s'est
imposé alors que me semble-t-il on a
déjà eu le débat autour de cette table
il me semblerait plus pertinent comme
c'est le cas dans les agglomérations
d'avoir partout sur le territoire
une limitation de vitesse qui soit
beaucoup plus étages et il y assure un
parcours des zones qui sont extrêmement
dangereuses et là il faudrait pas être à
80 il faut être à 50 quand bien même
vous soyez sur une route départementale
le temps d'enchaîner par exemple trois
virages et puis vous pouvez ressortir
vous êtes dans une grande ligne droite
ça n'a aucun sens d'être à 80 pouvait
être à 90 et non seulement ça
permettrait je pense que les gens se
disent mais voilà pourquoi on limite ma
vitesse
il ya une bonne raison je suis un
endroit où la route est dangereuse ça
permet de relancer en permanence la
vigilance du conducteur c'est à vous
demander en permanence à quelle vitesse
je dois rouler donc vous maintenez
le l'automobiliste éveillé et vigilants
et n'ont pas focalisé sur son téléphone
par exemple et surtout vous avez une une
approche de sa qui est simplement une
approche on est là pour vous protéger et
non pas en est là pour vous comprendre
c'est que si c'est quand même une
question si vous mettez 50 50 km h sur
une route nationale là vous allez avoir
des accidents
donc c'est pas simplement une question
de vitesse une question encore
dirigeants parce que ça va être trop
lent qu'effectivement les gens vont
cesser complètement subjectif s'il te
contredis 90 ça va mais la provence
qu'il ya des tas d'experts qui ont
travaillé sur ce ratio moi je n'ai même
pas spécialiste de la sécurité routière
mais il est aussi tout à fait notamment
enfin ils établissent très probablement
encore une fois je ne dispose pas des
chiffres mais on sait très bien qu'une
vitesse trop lente peut amener des
comportements qui sont accidentogènes
donc c'est une question d'ajustement
comme nous le disaient entre
l'environnement le contexte seul moteur
donc c'est pas il faut pas non plus
résoudre gardien calaisien sur le 80 oui
mais c'est quand même c'est quand même
aussi le coeur du problème c'est qu'en
effectivement la vitesse on sait ça 2-2
de science certaine que trop de vitesse
provoque des accidents ça m'apparaît
tout le reste pour vous des accédants se
téléphonent au volant propres le petit
joint il accompagnait le petit verre
avant de lire c'est à conduire avec ce
poids là revoici des accédants provoque
aussi des accédants volant ce qui est ce
qu'il va faire et sans programme ici
quand on lit cette étude c'est de voir
que le sentiment d'acceptabilité de
cette décision a quand même progressé au
fil de cette année puisqu'il ya
aujourd'hui si j'ai bien si je m'en
souviens bien moins 15 % de gens qui
refusent à tout prix
cette limitation à 80 ce qu'il faut s'y
ajuster une pragmatique et juste est
effectivement en fonction du rouge après
comme un effet collatéral pardon qui est
très très positif c'est la diminution
des gaz à effet de serre parce que quand
on sait quand on réduit de 10 km heure
ont réduit de 5 % sa consommation de
d'essence et donc on réduit les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
d'autant donc ça c'est très intéressant
nous internautes sont passionnés par le
débat voici quelques revues voilà
citoyens payeurs l'odyssée 80 km h et
une brimade administratives et au
passage un juteux fillon philon pardon
ça c'est un bon c'est un beau lapsus un
juteux filon avec un seul elle est
minuscule pour les finales alors que
colargol willy arrête on crie au complot
la muse la mesure coûte plus cher
qu'elle ne rapporte à l'état la sécurité
sociale fera des économies car la
vitesse réduite veut aussi dire moins
deux blessés et six qui nous dit si vous
voulez réduire les accidents sur les
routes remettait des trains à la
campagne remettait les petites lignes à
la campagne entre les villes